Really, really busy, right? So, he's not making it, you know, for these calls.
Yeah, no, not today. I think there was an issue with a little emergency scenario with a client that they were having to deal with or work through, so.
Phelps.
Hmm, OK, but we'll be glad to see him. I mean, whenever he has availability, you know, going further. Yeah, thank you, Lee, for joining in.
Baby.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Bless you, too.
Hey everybody. Hey Jonathan. Good to see you again.
Blue.
Yes.
How are you?
Doing well, how you been?
Good, good.
Hey.
All right, so Jonathan, apart from, you know, you, I know Kris is not joining, so are we expecting any more from your end to join in?
I don't think, I don't think so.
Okay. All right, so in that case, we can get it started. So thank you. Once again, officially, welcome to this call, Monthly Business Review. Sir, anything from your end before we get it going?
No, no, please go ahead, Gagan. I'll take it in the later on.
All right. Thank you, Team. So please allow me a few seconds. I'll present the service code presentation. It will be on your screens.
Yep, it is.
Thank you, Team. So this is for the month of May, which we're doing in the month of June, so which is why I'm mentioning here. So June, we are connecting in June.
From graphical standpoint, nothing much has changed. It is the same, but we'll soon be looking for some more beautification into these slides. Agenda items, I'll just quickly walk you through. However, nothing much has changed, but highlights, performance analysis.
ITBD CSAT, way forward with innovative technology solutions, AI by design, ITBD initiative, holiday schedule of Victor, and of course, recap, which I share after this call, with minutes of meetings. So I don't have to say it, but
But I always do. So please feel free to, and this is where everyone, and Jonathan for you as well. Please feel free to share your feedback, your insights or suggestions on anything that we're going to review further here. Thank you.
Not much. I kept it too. So Victor exceeded his ticket resolve rate in the month of May as well. And we'll discuss further on that. And he added to 100% attendance during this period. You know, because why I'm mentioning this, it shouldn't be that important because this was something
that Dylan touched upon a few months back. So we are consistently monitoring it. And yeah, so which is why he curbed this specific piece. He worked on it and refraining from taking unnecessary PTOs only when it's at most necessary.
Mhm.
Thank you. Anything from your end before we move on further?
For me?
Oh yes, this is for you.
No, no, all good.
Okay, thank you. Moving on to performance analysis. And yeah, this is for the month of May. However, I am presenting the April month as well so that we can have little, you know, a glance at it.
Billable target is 80%, however, his billable number remains sixty-six percent. We do not have any non-billables, as we know already, so, as per your previous feedback, so he's working very closely with with Casey, the dispatcher, so...
Mmh.
And I observed relatively less ticket inflow during this period of time in comparison to April. So.
That majorly contributed towards lesser billable numbers, although you know what I I check on check with him after every alternate day that are you working with Casey closely? Are you, you know, pinging him, texting that, you know?
that he must assign tickets to you. And he said, yes, you know, I always ping him. So if you observed anything, any other reason for lesser call info or ticket info from your end, you can, please, you can shed some light on it.
Yeah, I don't know of anything off the top of my head without kind of going back and reviewing everything, but
I mean, most of our textbooks stayed pretty busy with things, but...
I'm not sure.
Okay.
Unless we just haven't really had that.
that much to really...
That's alright.
Um, a sign out too much over that month, but...
Yeah, we'll keep an eye on that.
Sure, we can work on that, and if it, if it's required, so we can, you know, share information, exchange information with each other later on as well, you know, even after this call, anytime, any day or time in between our next service call. So, this month, as you can see, he
In the first week of May, the billable number remains 73%. On the following week, 65%, 66% and 61%. We'll see something more. You'll have better understanding once we see the next slide.
But.
Before I move on, any question you have about this?
Not for me.
Okay, thank you. Yeah, so here we see in the month of April, so you can see because when he was picking up to get on his own, so he was touching almost 70 plus tickets each and every day. 75, so green bar represents the number of tickets he is
picking up, he picked up and the blue bar shows the number of tickets he knocked down. He was able to resolve. So 75, 74, 79, 75. Although, I mean, if most of these tickets were maybe service quits, which is why, I mean, we wanted him to not to do cherry picking.
Mhm.
So that you know, Casey dispatcher can assign tickets, you know, as for best of his knowledge and understanding, but maybe this is a vacation season, so because other clients are also reporting that, so people have started to...
Okay.
go on vacation. So which is why I mean incident it has impacted incident service requests at the same time. Less ticket inflow. Yeah. So I hoping to see some some good inflow of tickets by going forward in the month of June, which when we'll connect again in July.
So yeah, this is the number. So 69 he test in the first week, was able to complete 57, then 58. And his resolve rate is impressive all the time, whether he's getting lesser or more above 70 or close to 80 tickets in a week. But
Yale.
he is able to finish up really quick. So we can see the amber line you see up on the top here, it shows 83 percent, 95 percent, 83 93.
Mm-hmm.
So, without impacting this, his ticket resolve rate, I my my focus would be to give him some more ticket if if this situation situation is understandable that tickets are not coming from the users.
So I think he can be utilized in some other activities, maybe some SOP creation or some reviewing some boards, reports where you can add value in your environment, maybe. Yeah.
Yeah, OK.
All right, thank you. Because ultimately our goal is to keep him productive.
Yep.
Or, if you, if you think...
There is some sort of.
A knowledge upgradation is required, his skill set, so, and he has a bandwidth, so we can assign him some training or some refresher course, be it technical or non-technical. Yeah, thank you.
Okay.
And I really do appreciate your team, Jonathan, you, Kris, and everyone for appreciating all what he's doing in your environment. And he received positive CSAT from Kris. So this time, you know, I know previously Kris was experiencing some issue with Team GPS and he said he was submitting
CSAT, but it was not getting registering at our end. So we worked along with Kris and he was, we were able to, our team was able to resolve that issue and he was able to submit this. So you might have received multi CSAT as well, but I understand you were in and out most of the times.
So, which is why we showed that to Kris, that Team GPS is resolved.
Yep.
Okay.
So, I, so I truly appreciate your team for recognizing Victor's efforts. Thank you.
Way forward.
Yeah, this has been my continuous focus that Victor to, you know, to support Victor all the time in meeting his KPIs. So this time, as we observed, his ticket numbers. So we'll work together on that and hopefully we'll see some improvement.
And if there's any kind of project work or advanced tasks that can be assigned to Victor, I mean, you can you can check with him or or you know, check with me because I have a team of experts here who will sit beside Victor. If he has any sort of if he requires any sort of advanced knowledge on.
Some particular tasks, so he can take support from internal my team here without, you know, bugging other team members and ITS who may be busy, you know, doing other tasks at the same time, I understand.
And lastly, but not the least, so this is this is from this is an initiative from our end from delivery side to keep team always engaged and so that they always feel like they're working not just in pressured working environment, but
Mhm.
in an environment where everyone is like a family. So we go out and dine for lunch or dinner together.
Yeah, that is it.
Anything from your end?
No.
Okay. And last time when Kris sent him some goodies, so Victor was really, really excited and he's really appreciated. You know, whenever I walk him to his seat, I still have that small, what do we call it, stress buster computer figure.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yep.
So, yeah, he still keeps that on his on his desktop, along with some die cast miniature cards. I mean, he has a collection of, you know, some die cast cards, you know, with which he has decorated his workstation. So, yeah, that's amazing to see.
That is it. And yeah, apart from that, so he has already availed his one option holiday that was Holi. So upcoming is Diwali. I mean, we have quite a few months to reach that day. However, we'll let you know at least two weeks in advance that he will be taking that holiday.
Okay.
The rest of these can be marked on his calendar. However, we are very open to support. If there is any sort of business requirement on these ITBD holidays, you can let us know and we can speak to Victor if there's a business requirement. Maybe most of your team members are out and...
He is required to be staying in the office to support the team, support the business. So I'm sure he wouldn't mind supporting the team to cover the shift that day and taking a day off later on.
Right.
No, all looks good.
Thank you. Yeah, thank you, Jonathan.
I pass this to set up. I think we have already touched upon that, but...
Yes, we can stop the screen sharing, Gagan. Thank you. So thank you, Jonathan, first of all, for sharing the current feedback. I'm glad things are moving in the right direction. And after our last conversation, I was able to share the agenda for the Build It Live along with the complimentary code where you can reserve your seats.
Alright.
So were you able to connect with Kris and make sure that we can reserve your spot there?
No, I haven't talked with him, but I think he had the information as well. So I'm not, I don't know that we're really planning to try to do anything this year as far as any conferences or anything like that. Just with a lot of changes going on with clients and things like that right now. So as long as we like to, I don't know that we'll.
Mhm.
It.
Kip.
We'll be able to kind of work it in the books for this year.
Is there something which we, Lee, or probably our CEO, Sunny, can help you out to make sure that someone from your team will be joining in? Because this is an event where more than 70 plus influencers would be there. And specifically from the MSP industry, we have 500 plus leaders. So it's a great
place for networking. Not only that, so the focus will be more on the leadership, the growth, the AI automation. So we have preserved a date dedicated for the AI, the kind of implementations which we have already been using. So that will be discussed. So that will be really beneficial in terms of long run.
So is there something which we as a team can help you out to make sure we can have you guys there?
I would just need to really just kind of talk to Kris about it a little bit more, honestly. It'll be kind of in his court to decide.
For sure, for sure.
Okay, no worries at all. The reason why I'm asking this because of the FIFA, the hotels are getting reserved on a faster pace as well. So we want to make sure that in case if you guys will be coming in, Kris will be joining in, or if you are tagging along, so when we have the hotel reservations done, everything should be
Ohh, yeah.
Gotcha.
easier for you. If you would like me, Lee, or even Sunny to call up Kris, I'll make sure that it will be taken care for us.
No, that makes sense.
Yeah, I mean, feel free to reach out because sometimes we just miss each other and forget to connect on things like this from time to time. Like, we'll have conversations, but it just ends up being one big like brain dump of like catch up kind of scenarios. And which is we ended up talking to him for like 30 minutes or 40 minutes after after hours yesterday.
Kip.
Yeah.
just, just say, hey, just catching up with you, see what's going on. And I just, we just kind of get in that mode of information stuff and I just don't think to bring it up at that time. So.
Okay.
No worries, hello.
Yeah, no, that's fair.
So what I have also done, Jonathan, while I kept Kris in the loop in the same email, Chan, so that it's easier for you to have that discussion, I have also shared some emails separately to Kris as well. And for the easier convenience, I have just posted the complementary code so that you can get.
Sure.
Yeah.
one ticket without any extra charges. That's BOGO 1495. It's there in the chat. Let me know. I'm just a text away. Me, Gagan, Kavan, Lee, all of us are. We are there to help you with the reservation or anything at all so that we can make sure you, Kris, and rest of the team would be there.
Okay.
Okay, much appreciated for sure. Yeah.
Yeah, we like to see our partners there as much as possible. So we come to you all first, especially when we know like the hotels tend to book up. And we have, I don't know if you're aware, I'm sure Sheridan publish, there's a big party we're throwing on the floor of the New York Stock Exchange this year.
Sure.
So that has a cap and we're running low on the space there. So we're trying to like anybody who's considering it, we're like, okay, well, let us know right away because we want to make sure that, you know, you get to party with the group and participate in that because.
Oh, that's right.
You know the Kaila, they always know these like kind of crazy experiences, Statue of Liberty and Upper World Trade was last.
Okay.
Boo.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, anyway.
And this time, it is New York Stock Exchange with the Great Gatsby Team.
Right.
Yeah.
Yeah, so...
Okay.
Cool.
Perfect. Rest, I believe. I'm all good for any other queries, Kavan, Gagan, anything from your end, or are we good for today?
I'm all good from my side. Thank you, sir. Jonathan, as always, thank you so much for your support and the feedback. We truly appreciate it. There it goes to Gagan, because he's the one who has been doing all the hard work, connecting with Victor, requesting him not to take leaves.
I will see him connecting with Victor. Yeah, so, yeah, but he is the one who's, you know, making sure that this, that things don't go south and he's able to pull things back. So, thank you, Evan, for your support. Best of, thank you. Thanks.
Yeah, no, you're welcome, and I believe...
Listen to me, listen to you, and listen to everyone. You know, Victor now is more mature. He understands, you know, what is the requirement? What do we expect out of him? So I think he understands, you know, not just when he takes leave, you know, his PT balance will be lowered.
But at the same time, other team members will be suffering because they'll be maybe someone else needs to be out on that particular day. And so they'll be bombarded with a lot of a lot of things and ultimately impacts business. So now we understand the bigger picture, which is why he cooperated and
curb this particular piece. So thank you. This is exactly what we want, Jonathan. Collaborative, you know, efforts from both sides. So if you notice anything, if you see anything, just say it to me and we'll fix that missing gap. Okay.
Yeah, no, seriously, I appreciate you guys' support as well with doing check-ins with him on your end also. So I think it's definitely helped get things in the right direction as far as, not to harbor on it, but yeah, the PTO things, that has calmed down quite a bit. So
I mean, I mean, obviously if he needs to take a day off or something sick or going on, you know, whatever, I mean, that's always understandable. So I think we already approved his next vacation coming up in a couple of weeks. Yeah, because I'm actually going to be off that Monday as well.
Yeah, yes, yeah.
But it's not a problem. We'll uh...
I know. You were my first point of contact, you know, borrow his PTO, so I called you. So, coincidentally, you needed to be out on that day. So, so I immediately called Dylan. And so I asked him to review him and if you need any backup resource to.
Yeah, yeah.
Yep.
to support the team during his absence. But he said, I think team is in, most of our team is in, so it may not be needed, so we'll be good. So he approved that. So I truly, truly appreciate you, your entire team, you know, how you support, you know, Victor.
And I believe that things are moving in the right direction and just knocking on the wood, so we'll keep things in the same place. Even better. So let's meet next month with more positive updates and or in between. I mean, if I feel like, you know, I'll
Yep.
have touch base with you, you know, on weekly basis as well, just to understand if things are moving right, if any attention is required, so we can work on that. Okay.
Okay.
Well, thank you very much, Team, for joining in. I appreciate your time. We'll meet next time, next month. Have a great day.
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you, Jonathan. Thank you, thank you. Bye bye.
Ticketing.